good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's been
kind of a rough couple days around here
so today I want to try to cheer myself
up by telling you a story about this
weird and beautiful moment in sports
okay so our story begins in 1984 at the
finals of the European Cup which is this
big soccer tournament where all the best
teams in Europe play each other today
it's called the Champions League and in
1984 the final game was between Roma and
Liverpool and at the end of the game it
was tied 1-1 which meant there had to be
a penalty shootout at the time
Liverpool's goalkeeper was this guy
named Bruce grovel R who was even by
goalie standards a pretty eccentric dude
and for some reason during this
incredibly high-stakes penalty shootout
he decided to feign wobbly legged
nervousness as one of the Roma penalty
takers approached and then that guy
skyed his penalty over the goal and
Liverpool won the Champions League 4-2
on penalties and Bruce grobble are
cemented his status as a Liverpool
legend but at the time this all happened
in 1984 the hero of our story Jerzy
Dudek was a ten year old kid living in a
coal mining town in Poland and as a
youngster Jerzy Dudek was like a pretty
good goalkeeper in his teens and early
20s he played for a third tier Polish
team but as he got older he became a
really good goalkeeper he found his way
to Holland and then eventually to
England where he played for Liverpool
beginning in 2001 now before we move on
to the story I just want to note that
professional goalkeepers practice trying
to save penalties a lot like by the time
Jerzy Dudek arrived in England he had
tried to save many thousands of
penalties when you're a goalkeeper
unless you're Bruce Grove are you learn
your way of saving penalties and for
Jerzy Dudek that was standing Stockstill
and waiting until like a half second
before the kick came in and then jumping
one way or another
okay so flash-forward to 2005 Liverpool
again find themselves in the finals of
what is now called the Champions League
with a chance to win their first
European Cup trophy since 1984 and Jerzy
Dudek is the goalkeeper there again
playing Italian opposition this time AC
Milan and for Liverpool and Jerzy Dudek
the game starts horribly at half time
they are down three nothing and they
weren't just losing they were getting
played off the pitch like AC Milan were
just a much better team and then
essentially out of nothing during one
six-minute stretch in the second half
Liverpool score three goals to tie the
game
and it remains tied for the next 30
minutes and then through all 30 minutes
of extra time thanks in no small part to
Jerzy Dudek at the end of extra time
Dudek made a double save so incredible
that to this day if you ask him about it
he says that he does not remember making
the save and does not understand how he
possibly could have made it so the game
goes to a penalty kick shootout your
Jerzy Dudek
you've been practicing saving penalties
since you were a kid you have your way
of doing it you've done your research
you knew this was a possibility you've
laid awake at night imagining it the
Champions League final down to penalties
you in goal standing Stockstill until
the moment before the ball is kicked
like you always have but then one of
your teammates Jamie Carragher walks up
to you and says that in 1984 twenty-one
years ago this guy Bruce growler did
this weird Crazy Legs thing while
defending penalties for Liverpool in the
European Cup final and it worked and
Jamie Carragher is like you should do
that but that was in 1984 with different
players and a different coach and a
different opposition what does that
moment have to do with this one quite a
bit as it turns out there are times in
your life when you do things precisely
as you have prepared and practiced for
them and then there are times in your
life when you listen to Jamie Carragher
so in the most important moment of your
professional life you start dancing you
don't actually know how Bruce grobble
are did it so you do your own version
and it works Milan's first penalty taker
sky's his shot over the goal and you
save two of the next four penalties and
Liverpool are European champions once
more I think about this moment a lot
partly because I'm a Liverpool fan and
we are notoriously mired in our own
history but also because it reminds me
that sometimes the right decision is the
weird decision Hank I'll see you on
Friday